and one of the news items that continues
to percolate and eventually may
simmer and at some point may boil and
still could full out explode
is the relationship between the
pittsburgh steelers and ben
roethlisberger now a couple of weeks ago
we were led to believe that there would
be a middle ground there would be a
resolution there would be a new contract
a contract pursuant to which the
steelers would reduce the ben
roethlisberger cap number from 41.25
million
all the way down to 22.25
million that is a difference of
19 million dollars and no i didn't do
the math just then if i had i would have
gotten it wrong
so how do you save money under the cap
and keep ben roethlisberger it's a
simple proposition you take the 19
million he's due to make this year you
turn it into a signing bonus you extend
the contract by a few years with some
dummy years on the back end 22 23 24 and
you spread out that 19 million payment
we've done the numbers before it
wouldn't take much to put his cap number
in the range of say
26 million dollars
now the extra 15 million would hit the
cap in the future more specifically
would hit the cap next year but that's a
way to do it you can rob peter to pay
paul under the salary cap if you want to
keep ben roethlisberger and it felt like
that's the direction it was going art
rooney the owner of the team made it
clear they wanted him back for another
year and ben said hey i want to come
back and he also said i don't care how
much money i make well
well
now here we are and i got to give credit
to ed bouchette of the athletic he made
the point a couple of weeks ago that
even though both sides seem to be
willing to work this out
there's no guarantee they're going to
work it out and until they work it out
wait for it
it's not worked out
so kevin colbert the steelers gm
says
that
there isn't anything that has worked out
at this point and he didn't close the
door on the possibility that ben
roethlisberger won't be back and that
would happen if the steelers just decide
to take the 19 million dollar cap hit
that they're going to take this year
anyway whether he's on the team or not
they're taking a 19 million cap charge
for past money past contracts past
restructurings the question is how much
more do they want to commit to
rothsberger from a cash or cap
standpoint and they could decide that
whatever number they're willing to do
is less than what roethlisberger is
willing to take he can say i don't care
how much money i make you can say it
if they offer you a million dollars the
league minimum
and he says nah i care a little bit more
than that i don't care but i care a
little bit more than a million dollars
that's how it all falls apart and it
could be the steelers are deciding this
that now is the time to rip the band-aid
off that now's the time to move on you
know i haven't been a fan of this idea
that we're going to ride one more year
with ben roethlisberger understand the
attraction that's what they did with
jerome bettis in 2005. the year after
the steelers got close to the super bowl
15-1 ben roethlisberger's rookie season
thrust into action after tommy maddox
was injured i can still remember seeing
the quotes from alan fanuka new hall of
famer who wasn't sold on the idea of
having a rookie from the miami of ohio
come in and become the starting
quarterback well they did well well
enough to get bettis to believe next
year could end with a super bowl trophy
the problem is right now do you really
think steelers fans out there
do you really think
there's a good chance your team's going
to win the super bowl next year
with what the salary cap is going to do
to the team with the fact that key free
agents won't be back like juju smith
schuster and james connor and that other
guys like bud dupree he's coming off of
a touring acl are they going to keep him
around they're going to have to cut some
guys it's going to be a very different
team and i know that mike tomlin is very
good about taking the guys he has and
making them into something better than
what they are individually but even then
you compete with the chiefs
bills
ravens
browns
not so sure about that
and it could be that
the steelers just decide now is the time
to move on now is the time to turn the
page now is the time
to draft a new quarterback or let's see
what mason rudolph can do you know
not many people were paying attention to
the week 17 game between the browns and
the steelers because the steelers
weren't really trying but rudolph wasn't
bad in that game he was bad in 2019 but
he wasn't bad in that game and that was
a game the browns were trying to win to
punch their playoff ticket so they could
go to pittsburgh and punch the steelers
in the mouth the following week
either way the road is going to come to
an end for roethlisberger and i would
prefer
if i was a steelers fan i'll try to put
myself in the shoes of a steelers fan
i'd prefer let's just be done with it
now because there's a good chance that
when you get to the end of 2021 you're
going to regret
that you continued the relationship i
don't like one more year not in football
i don't want it i don't like it it just
needs to end and you can maybe think
it's your final year it's better to not
enter into it that way and i think
that's what the steelers may be finally
realizing and the other side of it too
is i don't think anybody wants to be the
villain in this
if it ends rothsberger wants it to be
the steelers fault if it ends the
steelers wanted to beat roethlisberger's
fault rothersberger wanted too much
money he said he'd take anything he
didn't take
anything that we offered he didn't want
to come back i just think they they both
and particularly the steelers would like
to find a way to to step back from this
and move on and understand that 2021 is
going to be
you know we we talk about rebuilding we
talk about reloading i think 2021 for
the steelers and i think this is the
first time i've ever used this in
context with a football team it's more
like regrouping
because
we don't know what they're going to have
whatever they have mike tomlin is going
to find a way to make it in a contender
and then you figure out this year who
are the guys that provide the nucleus
for 2022
and if you get lucky and you exceed all
expectations and you get to the playoffs
and win some games and somehow snake a
path to the super bowl so be it it's all
gravy but at some point
the gravy boat that is ben
roethlisberger's career needs to end and
it could be that now is the time to do
it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports